hey guys what's up this is andrew for
transcendences.com so in this video guys
as usual we're gonna go through amc jme
press action
we have the fed meeting today so we're
gonna discuss uh what can happen during
this meeting which is in 20 minutes guys
uh
and
and we're gonna try to understand what
can happen next so let's get into it all
right guys so i'm gonna make a short
video because i mean
i have only one very interesting thing
to show you is this breakout all right
on amc
so i posted this in my discord this
morning so let me first show you the
situation first on the four hours time
frame
so
i'm talking about the switch pattern for
the past
uh
week i would say
and we were waiting for this breakout
here all right so i remind you guys
whenever we have a bullish divergence we
want to see
a breakout a candlestick pattern
rsi higher than 50 or
a
moving average crossover so two moving
averages that cross each other with a
lower time frame and higher time frame
or the price action crossing a moving
average all of that is a price action
signal that when combined with the
bullish divergence is creating a bullish
signal that usually gives a positive
reaction so here we have the bullish
divergence all right i showed you guys
that many many times right it's here as
you can see momentum going higher price
actually going lower right which means
that bears are out of steam
so then we were waiting for this bracket
and as you can see
clearly
i mean
you can't ignore the fact that
there were there was a
um a domino effect of stop losses we can
zoom in a little bit
but this happened very very quickly this
move here and i'm going to tell you
everything about this move all right it
happened roughly
in
i would say one hour all right
so
we are
looking at the forward time frame why
because this is where we have the
bullish divergence so we must
do
all of the analysis on the first time
frame so let's have a look at the volume
so
on the first time frame you can see the
volume is higher true but i mean
it's not incredible at all is just a
little bit higher than the lowest volume
we had recently so
it's not really a volume increase then
you're going to tell me yeah but if i'm
going i would
have a nice volume increase
okay true
but first the volume increase here
occurred on the red candle
so that's not good
and second
we cannot check the hourly volume for
forwards divergence combined with a
breakout because
i mean
this is the right time frame to use this
is where we have the buddhist divergence
so this is the time frame we need to use
to check the volume and
the time frame is fixed with the bullish
divergence and then we need to have
volume we need to have bulls taking back
control during four hours and we didn't
have that we had i mean we had a
breakout
uh but the volume is low so this is what
i said in the alert i put i posted uh
this morning
i said that yesterday's breakout is
validated because we closed the day
above all right
[Music]
that we had the buddhist divergence we
had a nice buildup once again you can
see we tested this trend line multiple
times before breaking it this is what we
call a buildup that always i mean should
happen on low volume look at those very
low volume so we had the nice buildup
with
[Music]
on low volume we had the breakout and we
closed above the 20 period sma once
again you check the 20 period
whatever the time frame you're using
right because this is the right time
frame uh the right moving average to use
for a crossover and here we had this
crossover so this was very positive now
uh we had some
signs that this breakout is not strong
the first and obvious one is that it
didn't ah
it didn't involved a big volume so we
had a small volume increase okay so
that's
already
a reason that is good enough for me to
say that this breakout is not a strong
breakout okay first thing then
you can go deeper in the analysis by
saying that the rsi is below 50.
if you don't know where to put your
breakout for when you see a buddhist
divergence you just combine it with a
150 rsi it works it works it makes money
it's not incredible and you're gonna
have algorithms in front of you that
basically because it's a systematic
strategy i prefer to use breakouts that
involved some subjectivity this is what
i'm explaining in my course by the way
for those interested the link is in the
description
um and
and you're gonna make money but
not a lot right let's be honest but
you're not going to lose money if you do
that 1000 times i guarantee if you use
of course the right stop loss and the
right
uh profit taking which is not easy but
at least you're going to have good
signals all right
uh rsi 150 so here it was smaller than
50 which shows that bulls are not back
in control the momentum is not 115 right
simple rule above 50 boost in control
below 50 base and control right so here
we have mixed signals then
we like to see whenever we have a
breakout we have to we like to see a
clean victory so we like to see a big
candle so here it was a small one and to
close at the top of the candle which
shows that those were in control during
the full uh candle four hours and then
you need to have volume so here we we
had mixed signals so what is happening
now now we pull back because this
breakout was i would say weak
usually you can use fibs
here
but in this situation as you can see we
retraced the whole breakout but it was a
small one so fair enough
and we found some support on this
trendline that is now support right it
was resistance it became support so
we are still in a situation clearly
where both are trying to take back
control and we're gonna apply the same
same things
so we need to have volume increase we
need to stay above the 20 period moving
average we're not below so we have a
fight all right we have a fight here but
with a first impulse given by bulls so
it's looking better than yesterday i
mean before i did my video
[Music]
but yesterday it was looking bearish
today it's looking i would say slightly
bullish but neutral bullish right it's
not a very strong bullish signal but
it's still very positive it's been a
long time we're waiting for that we have
earnings coming
in in a few days so this could have be a
catalyst for amc as well
uh all right guys so this is what i
wanted to show you i think it's
interesting once again it's the kind of
information i try to share in my discord
for those who want to learn join the
discord link in the description as well
um sorry for every gme fan but
i can't spend that much time on gme
because we don't have here anything
happening
we make zero today we didn't have a
breakout yesterday yesterday we moved up
70 beeps so once again i told you guys
the difference between amc and jamie
i mean right now is that gme is
consolidating horizontally so here it's
been three days we're not moving before
here
so
i mean for me the level to close above
is 130 as long as we are below that
bears and control
so that's pretty much it guys uh we can
quickly have a look if we have some
bullish divergences
we don't you can see the momentum is
flatish not going up
uh
because it was higher than amc amc
dropped heavily so the momentum was very
low and then whenever you stabilize the
momentum is increasing gme
is has a
momentum that is flattish and low so i
don't have a bullish divergence i don't
have a clear trend line
uh
it's just less
you know interesting in terms of
technical analysis uh to study this
situation we are
in a bit in a boring situation um
we need to have some you know
more information so that we can try to
guess who is doing what where are stop
losses here i don't have a clear vision
the only thing i see is above 130 bulls
are back in control so we're gonna
monitor that
then bam bam bam triple cube guys but
once again i mean uh the fed meeting is
in 15 minutes what is going to be
interested interesting so we expect a
plus 50 beeps increase in rates i mean
no surprise here it's 95 percent sure
maybe 99 sure it's gonna be 50 bps
increase what is going to be interesting
is the guidelines given by german power
with that will happen in one hour so i'm
going to listen to this of course
uh
because everything he's gonna say is
gonna be you know
um interpreted by investors and
it's very hard to trade i would
personally not trade unless i see
something obvious but i don't think i'm
gonna see anything obvious because we
are in a situation where
on triple q we are close to the lows but
we are far from the resistance far from
supports
so there's nothing i mean if i see a
move coming here i will sell it all
right so this is the only trade i would
try to do
if i see a massive move up
uh i will be selling this move up
uh nothing much to say guys best in
control on triple q i told you my
support is 280 resistance
330 then 338 is the pivot point the
major level to take back for boost to
try to be back in control on the long
term try
it's not because we go above that level
that booster bike can control but at
least it looks better
and last but not least all guys uh
as you guys know i'm bullish on
commodity
uh
pretty much every commodity
and of course on the oil market i'm
bullish as well
and we had
a few good opportunities
with a re-test of this long-term
breakout here
as you can see we've been testing it
once twice three times
i don't know if this time is the good
time but you guys know that the embargo
will happen soon with russia
on the gas probably first but the oil as
well uh i don't see how this market can
stay here
i think that
it will just we we we may we might very
well have a dip i'm not saying that you
know it's 100 win i'm just saying that
in a few months i will probably be
trading higher so this is the position i
have
it's protecting me against inflation
it's protecting me against um
you know the kind of dark scenario where
the war
intensifies and relations between
countries worsen and oil which is of
course affecting the oil price so i'm
having a hedge against that i'm having a
short position on triple q
and i'm long amc dme
many other stocks guys i'm not going to
tell you all the least but
it's been tough for my long positions
but i made good money on my short
position and on my
energy
plays as well
i've been playing this move for quite
some time so
that's the good thing
these days
so that's it for me guys i hope you
enjoyed this video uh tomorrow i'm gonna
debrief what's gonna happen after uh
fed's decision and especially jerome
paul's lines
um
and yeah that's it for today i hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget guys to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to sure i'll see you
guys